pues lo que pasa es que este virus por
las características de la transmisión y
además porque tiene un periódico acción
más largo que empieza en un tiempo más
después de haber tenido el contagio pues
podría ser más fácil de controlar y
también el hecho de que no es no se
transmita por aerosoles limita la
transmisión esto hace que obviamente no
hay que bajar la guardia y hay que
hacerlo de una vez en un caso
rápidamente hacia el cerco
epidemiológico para poder detectar a las
colas contactos y de esta manera evitar
la propagación estas dos características
del periodo incubación más largo y lo
otro que no se transmite por el aire de
hace que se limite o tenga más
posibilidad que se limite comparado con
la con 19